with the first afternoon session on the
transportation current and future trends
thank you David
I think it's fair to say that since the
dawn of humanity we have been obsessed
with trying to capture you know the
Earth's surface as a new graphical form
and part of what drives that I think is
that no amount of oral or written
description can really capture the
richness of you know of topographic
topographical data that have got a map
captures right so good afternoon my name
is Vanessa time a director product at
lift I'm here to talk about mapping and
then trying to look at where we're at
right now and what has been happening to
last several years and we're going in
the future I'm gonna be talking a bit
broadly about mapping than just what we
do at lift specifically so you know
hopefully we try to cover again the
trends we didn't ignore mapping tech
itself plus also what are the
applications that that use mapping and
how they have been pushing the forefront
of mapping as well so a little bit about
myself first so I spent about a decade
or more doing Naoko research in computer
vision now I have a PhD in the field
spent several years at Siemens research
after that focusing on detecting objects
detecting cars humans and so on so forth
then I was a part manager at Google Maps
I was responsible for their road network
and navigation data then before I left
my team was one of the first teams I
built out the machine learning
algorithms to analyze Street View and
aerial imagery to better build maps at
scale and going back in the past I was
the PM for Street View and also we
capture we capture as you know is the is
the spam protection tool and we launched
that I'm not a robot thing presently I'm
a I'd left focused on mapping very
specifically on autonomous vehicles like
know what does mapping mean and that's
in that space and in the past I've also
been looking at the core mapping aspects
of lift so lift as you may know is one
of the fastest-growing ride-sharing
company in the United States today we do
on the order of around 10 million rides
week and we cover about 95 personal u.s.
population and because we have coverage
in all of the 50 states again the longer
term ambition of left really is to is to
really be 95 percent of the US
population has access to lift service
you can call a lift they can so lift
again the ambition of you know what we
want to do is you know really be a
redefined transportation as a service
and in doing that I think one of the big
aspects we want to push forward on is
also you know work on autonomous
vehicles with so --lifts approach to
autonomous really is twofold we're
taking it the first approach really is
what economy open network approach where
we have anyone you know out there who's
developing an autonomous vehicle you
know any power any partner of us to
bring the technology into a network plug
in and be able to deploy that on a
network right
that's what work on the open network and
again the idea here is to democratize
and accelerate the development of
autonomous vehicles by providing a means
for them to start no plugging in and
servicing the customers own network the
second piece is the is what we're
calling a level 5 effort level 5 is our
own effort may be a Deltan the whole
tech stack of the photon vehicles as
well and again the idea here really is
to to build out our own tech stack and
able to actually deploy so a lot of
exciting things happening here so coming
back to them the mapping a spent an you
can see why mapping is so near and dear
to us because we need to really
fundamentally understand the physical
world so that you know we can operate
both our code it whether it was in the
future into the autonomous now when you
talk about mapping most of us I think
you remember you know the days when we
used to open up a paper map and then try
and find figure away you know where we
are autumn this and so on
well the last decade or so a lot has
happened in the consumer space right
we've gone especially from him to open a
paper map every day basically having
navigation on our phone with us all the
time right the point of a never lost
anymore it and so the transition really
has been going on the consumer side
isn't going from paper maps to be able
to actually navigate in our on-demand
but wherever you want but I think a lot
more has been happening and a lot more
is going to happen in the in the
enterprise space in the commercial side
of things and I also touch upon of
you of the areas that are actually going
to really benefit a lot from mapping
data as well as be the defining
technologies that actually push a very
specific requirements back into what
mapping needs to be so it moves the
mapping area forward itself so
autonomous is an obvious one right for
cars to drive on physical street they
need to fundamentally understand the
world in a very different way than has
ever been required before right so what
does that entail we talked about this a
little bit more the ride-sharing itself
let's so for I Tring to work you know we
have to match the drivers and the
passengers and both of them need to be
able to specify a where they want to go
and be the driver needs to know how to
get to the SIRT to pick up the passenger
right augmented reality this is another
big area where just which is pushing the
forefront of what what what it means to
be doing mapping because you need to be
able to have a really strong
understanding of you know where your
device is pointed or what is it what is
the world the see looking at drones and
you know by the back station flying cars
again we need to have a very deep
understanding of what's going on around
them and and people don't honestly put
this together but you know just digital
advertising right a lots been happening
in that space and a lot more is gonna
happen when we have a better
understanding of the the physical world
at the center of all this really is
mapping you have it online and you right
in the centre of location-based about
all of these areas you know in the
Decker's bill so the core if it is all
is mapping there's a set of code data
that that powers a lot of these
applications each of these applications
might have different requirements in
terms of what subset of the data it
needs to look at what accuracy
requirements they might have and so on
so forth so the narrative the stock can
roughly be divided into two parts you
know one aspect of it could be how has
mapping technology been evolving in the
last several years and where is that
going the second release evolution of
applications what are the new
applications are coming onboard which
are pushing the state-of-the-art in in
mapping and I'll try and try and cover
both of these areas again it is it's
going to be a small cut of it this area
is much much bigger than what I can
prevent in the next 15 minutes but you
know hopefully it'll give you a flavor
of what's what's entailed here
but first what is a map right so if you
if you if you ask what I'm port really a
map is you can look at it as being a
like a layer cake wherever you have
different layers and very coarsely
speaking there's about three or four
broad layers you have the political is
an orientation right you have the
network and then you have the places of
the pairwise and the polar is really a
country boundaries your state boundaries
your zip codes and so on so for that
this is basically the the table stakes
of what a map really is a level up the
network is your fundamental road network
you know what is it what kind of road
geometry do you have what are what kinds
of remotes are they are the freeways are
there side roads and so on so forth but
the other traffic traffic lights there
are other stop signs I level up you're
looking at points looking at businesses
you're looking at places of interest
you're looking at what's called geo
codes in industry Agia code something
most of us take for granted but in the
mapping industry is very hard to get
tried which is like if I type in an
address
1 2 3 Main Street where in the world is
that located backside lat/long of that
right there is incredibly hard to get
right right and this is one of the big
areas where a lot of folks spend a lot
of time trying to get right so jumping
into the evolution of mapping technology
people have been trying to do mapping
for a very long time right I think this
whole thing in the u.s. at least began
sometime in the 1880s when the USGS was
was set up to begin a systematic
topographic mapping of the United States
it was an extremely manual effort people
physically sent out to start surveying
the physical area and there was another
person who would actually sketch busines
what this person was saying right but
they did amazingly far with this for
this with this approach right and and a
lot has happened since then to the late
20th century but I won't go into all of
that stuff I will fast forward to the
you know the the beginning of the 21st
century where where a lot of things
changed fundamentally because both
things launched right satellite imagery
began becoming plentifully available
completely digital globe and GOI
launched satellite that for the first
time allowed a wide swath of the country
in the world to be accessible to people
to see from the space right and this
really you know showed a new era of map
making as well as consumer interest in
the space around 2003 or 2004 there was
a company called keyhole eventually
acquired by Google which
Google Earth which for the first time
let users consumers on the road you know
just see what the world looked like from
space right and I don't know if you guys
remember this but I was a grad student
back then and I spent hours doing this
is a complete time suck right but but
this is the consumer side of things a
lot more is happening on the on the on
the mapping side the same data can
obviously be used for mapping right so
you pick a satellite picture like that
and you start tracing stuff on that you
start tracing your roads you start
tracing your lane geometry you start
tracing all of these things that we can
see from space
well now suddenly you have a map right
and what that lets you do is it lets you
capture course base map features these
are things you can see at that scale
reports not really fine-tuned so you can
look at low it's a road type you can
look at Lane information you can see
building geometry what is the building
shape like you can look at parking
structures and so on right to some
extent what is have been happening in
the last several years is that because
this data is so plentifully available
and because it is you know relatively
straightforward to start labeling and
tracing over this data among all the
different map data providers this set of
data is Mallis I would say commoditized
right you can't really separate out
between different providers if the road
network itself is for the most part
people have got that right now of course
with a brand new road gets constructed
there might be a latency in how quickly
they catch up but for the most part this
is this is you know I would say caught
up by a lot of folks the pace where it
gets tricky is street level features
right so the next aspect going a level
deeper is very street level imagery any
serious map data provider has one of
these vehicles running around right and
the most popular of them obviously as
you know is Google Street View where you
have millions of miles of data where
they've driven the car physically and
captured pictures from the street level
what this lets you do is it lets you
capture finer grained
information about the world so it's not
just enough to see the road geometry you
won't know how the roads interconnect to
each other right can I take a left turn
from here oh is a right turn prohibited
is that a one-way street these kind of
things are almost impossible to infer by
just looking at a satellite picture
right so street names businesses
geocodes again street number so we
street numbers if you know one to three
main streets on the street and one to
three is a dislocation here you can
infer that that's the lat/long of that
right now of course the downside of this
is that the coverage and refresh are
very expensive driving a car dedicated
to mapping all over the world and then
doing it again multiple times you know
is not cheap right it comes at a cost
furthermore this is a huge amount of
data right
typically mapping is done you know using
human workforce where I kiss stares at
these pictures and tries to annotate
them to actually build a map but this
data it's it's it's the amount of
information is so large it gets
extremely hard even for human ops to
keep up yes I'm glad you brought that
desk outsourcing is definitely a
possibility I'm hesitating because I
there was a slide on my deck they move
up to the back that I'd say actually
answers that question I'll bring it back
up actually let's talk about that
so yes labor is it's really by intensive
the second piece third piece really is
that you need human operations most of
map data will need a fairly non-trivial
amount of human operations again a large
companies that do mapping have order on
order of hundreds or thousands of people
who are annotating data who are labeling
information and who are busily building
the map state information right and of
course there's a whole point of trying
to manage this whole operations that
itself is challenging but now what about
automation so the automation a lot of
advances have happened in the last you
know in the last several years that lets
you take imagery detect objects in them
and then be able to infer you know what
you see and then try to build a map
right especially with the advent of deep
neural networks you know it has with
respect to computer vision simple
objects have become fairly
straightforward to actually detect them
the hard piece is that even if you do
this the at the bar for automation to
actually go into a map is actually very
very high with map making there's really
no room for error if you say it's a
one-way street it better be a one-way
street right because you know the cost
of a person going the wrong way is
actually extremely high right so there
still is some element of human or
moderation that comes into play and this
couple of papers are highlighted here
that of the work that we did
I was at Google and again this is not to
say that these are the only two papers
that advance the state of the art
there's a lot of work here this is the
stuff that we talk about publicly that
that's published work so right here
really with this one here was that we
actually sparse street view pictures
pixels and found street numbers right
and once you have the street numbers
because the Street View car is well
localized doing exactly where the
numbers located and that helps you get a
geo code of the right location and this
is completely non-trivial because now
you have algorithm that is able to do
this at scale across you know pretty
much the anyway you have street level
imagery the same thing here in this in
this thing what you're seeing really is
that we were able to identify the extent
of a storefront what is a extent of a
business storefront read the title of
the business and then be able to create
a business listing out of that right so
again very very hard in fact it was been
difficult for humans to say exactly what
is the extent of a storefront because
it's not very well defined okay lots of
advances here crowdsourcing you brought
it up so again there's a if you can
crowdsource something you should route
suicide right because that is
significantly cheaper and more
accessible than then trying to do this
using your own in-house operators I
mentioned you know recapture earlier so
recapture as you know is one of those
things where you know you could actually
leverage that front on the crowdsourcing
angle as well because some information
there is known others is not known that
unknown piece is what you know you could
use to label so that was the piece that
that also helped quite a bit on this one
you know mechanical cuts yes but it's
also the other way mm-hmm when I was
looking for some patience for the space
it isn't big
imagine that everybody starts ordering
online yeah
and the deliveries begin to happen this
is in my interest to give you the exact
lat/long of my addresses my location on
the magic this is a straightforward
incentive including things like you know
entry security numbers but a building
that is actually very hard to get but
this time self interested in doing this
right I think that makes me little
somehow explore the war maneuvers
so I think I would make a distinction
between I would say what what you're
talking about here where people are they
have they they want a service and
they're kind of getting data back for
that space versus people who are doing
it for a specific cause by either
getting paid or you know they're doing
it in a that's case right so when people
are drivers that means us to this
user-generated content right so this is
another big aspect of things right so
the thing is what we saw earlier was you
have lots of other imaginary data you
parse that and extract information from
that and anybody's map sort of that but
that has limitations the biggest
limitation is actually fresh it's not
only super fresh you cannot drive and
you cannot fly a satellite all the time
of the frequently enough but the other
aspect of what if you could get your
users to come contact data back to you
my map is broken here right that isn't
this this roadway is not even there
let's go and actually put that in right
so if you're able to get users to
directly engage with your product and
and contribute data back then you know
and you're able to make it sustainable
that's when you get you know significant
impact in fact and in fact this can
actually span multiple types of you know
you could have a very sophisticated user
who's able to actually go in and edit
road networks make them interconnected
and do a great job there or you might
have a user who can just answer a yes/no
question right
is this is there a retail accessible
entrance to the restaurant yes or no
right so so the range of what
do in that space and if they're also
passive and active you see passive means
that now you know as you're walking
around with a phone you're you know your
phone is emitting a GPS signal and if
there's a row or maybe nobody seems to
go on that one's probably blocked right
so that's that's a passive inference you
can make based off of that
what is active you actually ask them is
the road blocked or not open street not
is a very interesting product where
there has been pretty much entirely
built off of data that people have
contributed have donated back to them
right whether actually physically tried
to label this term they've got or four
million users forty five thousand
monthly actives and you know millions of
edits that come in every day and this is
entirely free right people can use that
of course a problem here really is that
spam can be a problem
people can willingly go and try to add
bad stuff to your data and so moderation
is also actually critical part of this
so that was the the tech piece of it so
the real message here is that tech is
advancing to a point where machine
learning is making a big impact here
right what what used to be you know what
what you could do with human ops no you
can do it with machines and the second
piece is where users are getting a lot
more engaged with the products and using
that you know you data back now with
applications let's talk a bit about
ride-sharing right
so with traction the key problem really
is to get people from point A to point B
right and and and what the needs here
from the product perspective really are
first of all you have to understand what
a and B are in fact it also wasn't where
I need to go pick up a person and ready
to go drop the person off so not just
enough to know where the business is
right you need to be able to compute
accurate ETS how long will all of these
drivers take to get to come pick this
one person up but that's what really
helps you decide the optimal driver
right you need to be able to meet her
accurately this is the first time where
you don't have physical meter attached
to the car but it's simply using the GPS
on the phone to calculate what is the
distance and what not good at computer
travel and of course you would navigate
efficiently you need to understand how
people you know how to route so we can
match multiple passengers together so
number of challenges here you need to
make sure the Geo codes are correct you
to understand traffic you need to have
accurate GPS or at least be able to work
on the errors in ecology pace and of
course have accurate maps data on the
autonomous side it gets a lot more
complicated right here first of all
a map really simply a precomputed
understanding of the world right so
instead of trying to figure everything
out on the fly you precompute that and
put that in the car and the car uses
that guy to navigate the world so this
is really maps for robots and here
really what you're looking at is that
you need to very precisely localize the
car in the real world and once localized
you need to have a very deep
understanding of how the lanes
interconnect how the roads flow how you
know what exactly the car has to do in
static wood so this image here really is
is is the is a point cloud using lidar
that lets the car understand exactly
where you are is about five hundred
accuracy right and then this picture
here it kind of gives you a sense of how
complex the road networks can be for
with the lanes and how they
interconnected to each other so the cars
can then navigate them so and of course
the big challenge here really is to be
able to to automate the stuff the
eventual goal with autonomous vehicles
is not to actually build Maps all the
time rather actually have the car be
smart enough to be almost build a map on
the fly able to understand what it sees
is just like a human driver and have a
course level navigation but the car then
is smart enough to figure out how what
it needs to do when a Encounters
encounters no obstacles in that reality
another application where you need to
have much more deep unstring of the
world the point really is that this only
works if you're able to localize your
phone or whatever device with six
degrees of freedom you need to know a
lat long elevation and you need to know
your pitch and roll right once you know
this you can place your you know your
Pikachu we know wherever you want in
that scene right and so the problem
obviously here is that how do you hyper
look how you know how do you localize so
precisely and you know people have been
using this visual slam for a very long
time and and that has been evolving but
still accuracy issues with that and
there's obviously the operational
complexity of building that map in the
first place very similar to this point
cloud I showed in the previous one the
difference is that this is coming from a
lidar where you actually shoot a laser
bounce and get back well here what
you're doing is because you have a
dually a camera sensor you do a visual
you pick a feature point
camera moves you do a triangulation you
get a 3d point so it's similar but it's
coming from a different way there's
different editor characteristics around
around those points
with drones autonomous drones again the
point is you need a 3d map of the scenes
so you can navigate properly you need a
similar localization that was then the
example and so again the same issues of
visual slam apply here as well the last
thing advertising right so here again
the idea is that there was a big move
going from physical ads to digital ads
where we could for the first time
measure when people click on the ad but
what's happening now is that we actually
mouse and measure in-store visits so
I've clicked on a link and actually
physically go to the store problem with
that does GPS is extremely bad right and
so there's a lot of noise there but to
be able to parse it well you need to
understand what is the geometry of the
building where are the businesses
located exactly there so when people go
to you you're able to trigger against
that right and so this could again if
properly solved could unlock a lot of
value in this chain so this is a very
quick overview of you know two things
the mapping technology itself how it is
how its evolving and to the applications
that that I trip powering that IQ using
mapping and going back they're giving
very unique requirements back to this
the tech stack so it can move forward
right if done right mapping out here
could potentially unlock on the order of
several possibly hundreds of billions
worth of value to all of these companies
here
[Applause]
what about using drugs they're sleepy
what about it well if it's autonomous
probably yes but that's the same
question for autonomous cars as well
right how much something you have to do
once in your lifetime because the states
won't change very often and how much is
sort of traffic and situation dependent
people dating surpressing a lot of it
changes over time including roads and
you know what you think would not change
a lot so in general I think because no
because the thing is you know the lanes
are regularly closed so roads actually
physical roads are closed so although
you might have an assumed the underlying
structure your actual operation on that
will be impacted right so it's not like
you know I have this road once it's
going to stay open all the time that
doesn't necessarily exist when roads are
changed like that it's that there's a
city of someone who's doing the road
languages so like with with GTFS Google
encouraged the cities to provide
real-time updates on their service
disruptions can you persuade cities to
provide real-time it's very hard it's
really hard right so four different
cities will have different degrees of
sophistication with respect to how they
provide data and even when they do that
it's not consistent it's not timely it's
it's extremely hard to rely specifically
on the cities in an ideal world yes but
in practice that's not what happens
Google's lunch at Google is just out
because you guys are all these vehicles
roaming around it to be discussing okay
okay thank you very much again right so